where are some of the philosophies you
guys got where you lose people when you
not maybe you lose people but you get
some people i think it's triggered our
stance is not cheating um what that
really means what loyalty is what trust
is yeah uh you want to go and think
about that yeah i mean uh so a big
reason why people get triggered is that
we have a lot of as you guys know we do
a podcast uh we have a daytime podcast
that we do monday wednesday friday and
then we do our nighttime show with the
girls and what since it's longer form
content where podcast goes easily
between
from two all the way to five hours
sometimes and you know we have
discussions with with women uh you know
a lot of girls from all different types
of walks in life we're talking you know
any everywhere from like educated women
to only fans girls to strippers to
models whatever it may be attractive
girls to not so attractive girls girls
in all different types of demographics
and people take clips from these
conversations and you know they take
obviously something that's like crazy of
that i say you know put it as a clip and
then put it out there and if you put it
out there it might look wild right so
then people oh my god you guys are
massages whatever but if you saw the
entire context of the conversation what
led to that you know portion of the or
that clip you'll see okay now that makes
sense so a lot of people clip our stuff
in general or like for instance for
virality sometimes you'll kick a girl
out yes that's like obviously people
want to focus on the fact that all right
get the hell out yeah but what were the
five minutes before that you've asked
them repeatedly hey stop disrespecting
the podcast yeah stop doing side chatter
i've been there i've been on the podcast
well let me let me let me okay so let's
go let's go a little bit deeper let's go
a little bit deeper because so far
uh uh i don't have a lot of things that
i have uh everything makes sense so far
to me define to me how you view
uh what an alpha is and what a beta is
right i heard roller's definition maybe
you guys got a different one that you
have but how do you see what would you
define as somebody that's an alpha
versus a beta
man these terms man yeah we typically
don't even really use those terms man i
i know a lot of people use it for you
like you'll say you yeah why would you
call them you said something about uh
the
one of our supporters sent us a clip
right of him talking about us and it's
funny because like they're like yo this
white knight is simply trying to talk
about fresh and fit but he's a ship and
it's like yo real talk i don't know what
to do but how he was sounding it's kind
of i don't know i don't know so except
basically if i'm going to define it it's
basically a guy that gives his attention
resources energy whatever it may be to a
woman that isn't necessarily
reciprocating for what he wants which is
what nine out of 10 times intimacy so
that's if i'm going to boil it down
that's a simple i will say that david is
not a sip right for the audience out
there he's actually uh you'd be actually
impressed with that dude he is maybe a
white knight but not a thing if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]